How do you guys
feel like we get --
we get ourselves in the door?
How do we get ourselves
in the door more?
I don't know, man.
You know I sold a show, I sold
a semi-autobiographical sitcom,
and I sold a dramedy.
And the sitcom
crashed and burned
because they did
not want to tell
a mainstream disabled story.
They wanted those
tropes, so I was
hired to make a
really fun, sassy,
like Sex in the
City type of comedy.
And I had producers
actually tell me
that if my character
was too successful
I'd make normal people feel bad.
She was stripped of
her love triangle,
and instead was pining for
someone she was invisible to.
I asked them to not
mention the disability.
I wanted the character
just to live,
and be disabled because I was.
And then later in the series,
when the plot dictated,
we would discuss the disability.
They literally
had her screaming,
I have cerebral palsy,
off the bow of a ship.
Like an homage to a really
old, unfunny Titanic joke.
It was so hard for
me because there
was no other disabled writer.
So when I would tell
them things were ableist,
things were inspiration
porn, they didn't believe me.
They thought that I was just
trying to dictate storylines.
And they couldn't
understand what
it meant to be offensive
to disabled people,
because what they
were forcing on
me were the stories that
had always been told.
So I think the biggest part
of getting through the door
is accepting the fact that
just creating your own stuff
is not enough.
We need disabled people on
both sides of the camera,
because it's just
too much pressure
to be the only
person in the room,
and have to be like educator,
advocate, and artist.
Right, to your story
Maysoon, I have
quite a few of those as well.
I think one of them was
during a four camera shoot,
and one of the network execs,
said about my character,
who had nothing -- my character
had nothing to do with
my dwarfism at all.
And so their response was,
can't we play with him somehow?
I didn't understand what that
meant, but I knew it was bad.
I remember you telling me
that you had to tell people
to stop having your
character bite butts.
Yeah that's --
The thing that they
always had you doing.
-- That's a whole other line.
I've actually had to
put in my contract
that I will not bite
someone on the butt.
Any advice for young
folks coming in?
My advice for young
folks coming in.
You have to be better than
everyone else, I'm sorry.
You have to work harder,
you have to rehearse more,
you have to be better,
you can't be just as good.
It's the only way you're
going to get through the door
and shine.
Do more than one thing.
So like I'm a comic, but I
also commentate on the news,
I write graphic novels,
I do voice-overs.
Figure out at least two other
things that you're good at that
make money.
Because you need to make
money in order to pursue this.
And if you're trying to
make money off of this
it will kill you.
So find a way to make
money, in the genre,
that doesn't include
carrying 50-pound scripts.
So that people know who you are.
People trust you, and people
want to work with you.
And don't be afraid to
ask for accommodations.
Like Eryn said, if
you have a team,
have them pack it
into your contract.
If you don't have a
team, don't be afraid.
Again, all of Hollywood
is high maintenance.
You're not going to
be the person who
breaks the $100 million budget.
Don't be afraid to ask
for the things you need,
you're worth it.
I think find and
follow your passion,
because it's the only thing
that will propel one through.
None of us do this
for the money.
We do it because we love
it, because we can't
imagine doing anything else.
I do it for the money, 100%.
I think that's bad,
but I swear to god,
I do it for the
money it's not --
No, you don't.
You love what you do.
I do.
It's the red carpet, like
my stylist got me this suit.
I swear to you, I do
it for the gift bags.
[LAUGHTER]
Well, I can't really
argue with that.
You know it's true.
I guess I would say, follow
your passion and be authentic.
So Maysoon, you hit it.
[LAUGHTER]
I will add one other
thing to everything
you guys said, because you
kind of all covered my answer.
In this industry you
have to find your voice,
and find that space that you
fill that no one else does.